[Music]
I'm trying to think of other players who
also have like that competitive or
championship about them and a Cristiano
Ronaldo he missed the birth of his twins
because he was playing soccer I love it
was it just a regular game - is it a
league I think it wasn't like a big
championship it's like just cuz not the
game is the story yeah mister birth in
twins why you gotta be there so you're
not really doing it I push back on guy
he'll be in there for the birth I do
because I'm not a dick what is what what
is gonna happen you don't want to be
there to see what's gonna happen is your
son is gonna be born that's gonna add
your son be born okay and then what you
want to be there for that okay look it
would be dope it would be dope you know
who's not gonna remember it the son my
son right
so why be there the first year say yeah
why be there at all you told my feeling
apparently you'll not be there to like
three thirteen thirteen twelve or
thirteen above before thirteen sagen you
remember your life no no you remember it
but like it's not really anything
important or valuable like it's not real
parenting for a man until like 12 or 13
you know I believe that 100% I truly
believe that you just dare being a good
example as a man but disciplining in
that [ __ ] that's all mom until about 13
or 14 maybe in 15 I hope you showed he's
lizard it right now hundred percent I
believe that a hundred percent 100
percent why I admire you because I think
you might got the Jordan mentality I
also worry about you thank you my god
why would I discipline my kids we could
discipline the kid outside my discipline
talk about being there no I'm a be there
I'm gonna be a dope dad we're gonna go
play catch whenever we want to play
catch but if you do something wrong your
wife is gonna
I'll need to be there yeah you think
that's fair that's a different common
why would I sacrifice my kid loving me
but you said you didn't even me so funny
the [ __ ] [ __ ] so the reality right
oh right
great thank you now what is your kid
there's some annoying shits you like you
smacks you in the face
no no no I look at my wife yeah what
kind of kid you really gonna be like hey
hold on let me go get mom yo go talk to
your mom I saw what you did why would my
kids slap me in my face because you're
never there
mr. media be there I'ma be around all
that right that being said it's more
responsibility on Y feet for the
beginning for the beginning what your
dad really discipline y'all at a young
age yeah yeah stop it universe me say
what never got spanked no clearly not
you see why for what Oh what think about
it let your dad's really came down on
you at a young age yep you think your
kids will respect you when he when he
does some [ __ ] [ __ ] to you and then you
go let me go get mom and then and then
your kids gonna be like wait I gotta do
anything to dad he just doesn't care son
this what you do what you do teach your
kid to be a man is he disrespects you
and you say honey this is why this is
why y'all crazy right a little talk to
me is why y'all crazy right now a kid is
gonna do something disrespectful to me
yeah
Matt how would he know not to cuz I'm
the dad he doesn't even know what that
is son you yes he does he's never
existed before
hundred percent I come around and you
[ __ ] know silverback gorilla
smell it smell it all the time it is
right when Dad walks to your room is
different than when mom little
pitter-patter and do you know why I'm
afraid of my dad walk in my room why he
beat the [ __ ] my dad never needed to do
that [ __ ] to me my day it was easy like
work just walk to the room but what were
you afraid of him because afraid of my
dad yeah I was afraid yeah I was fearful
he said feel my fear mama never did
anything I never disrespected and yo you
know what's a real [ __ ] not only did I
never disrespect my dad ever not even a
single time not once in my whole life
any time my mom my dad would fight about
some [ __ ] I bet yo my mu chill the for
what it was I would take my dad's side
of [ __ ] heart but you're not as
easygoing as your dad either so what
that is easygoing can I be honest I
think I like my dad more than y'all like
your dad's let's be honest about it
pushing back conversation my dad y'all
guys dad's didn't my dad that my dad did
anyway where my loyalty is to my dad
said until we die bro nah don't be
questioning your dad's no I think you a
mark probably good time my father's it's
my father's no more bro not even close
my dad more than I like your dad my dad
my dad barely remembers me I still like
him more
whenever he remembers me I'm like five
science scholarship so long as he's
defying science that's the type of love
you come from is a different strategy
it's a different daddy strategy I'm
telling you your dads are busy
disciplining you and then y'all resented
them you know I [ __ ] this [ __ ]
my dad was like yo mom gonna hear that
y'all wanna play I don't mind a
discipline ping-pong played me left
handed so I could win that's how you did
well if your dad never did anything to
make you fear him why'd you fear him
it's in here it's not about fear I don't
want to let him down that's the thing
you have to lead by fear my dad didn't
leave I fear I didn't want to let him
down bro that got the [ __ ] goat that
guy always there no matter what when I
need it man I can't let that guy down
bro so he was your Steve Kerr and our
dads were Michael Jordan oh you mean
they weren't there for their kids yeah
oh this is Blaine your kids bro what
happens at 13 when you're like all right
charlie whatever your kids dumbass name
is yeah every once in a while you need
to [ __ ] some [ __ ] up yo but my dad could
do without being like brutal like this
is a thing and I realized his strategy
my dad anything that we wanted he would
always just go do anything we needed go
do doesn't matter whatever it was and
then when you did something that he did
not approve of that's where he closed
off and he just had to shake his head
shaking his head that's way Brad you
punched me in my face because I can heal
from you punching me in my face I can't
heal from me disappointing you mmm the
idea of like I remember once we were in
Barcelona and my parents came to visit
right my mom never visited me once in
college the second I go to [ __ ]
Europe she's like we should take a
joy yeah up a little bit right and I
remember where he was watching me play
basketball and the idea of losing and
basketball in front of my dad was like I
couldn't I couldn't imagine it and I
lost guy flew all the way out to
Barcelona it was a pickup basketball
game but we lost the Spanish kids to
Spanish I was so [ __ ] embarrassed I
was so um I didn't care is I gosh it's
great to watch you play I could not
believe the [ __ ] levels of
embarrassment he put that in me somehow
I don't know how but I feel like that's
the greatest that's the greatest
motivational technique if you can do it
is making someone not want to disappoint
you so yo you binding the Steve Carr
coaching model mm-hmm what you're buying
into this TSST for coaching models
positivity its positivity be there do
what they want have a good relationship
with them and then they won't want to
disappoint you I don't ever compare my
father don't thing you've ever said to
me I'm not comparing you to Steve Kerr's
father-son let's table this for a
flagrant like tomorrow
my dad remembered Jamil yeah we got a
cut but I remember Jamil yesterday like
I went hang out so my dad to lose his
memory tena Bayless my right and losing
it and he's just having the most fun he
just come he's a perfect example of like
just acceptance of life yeah like he
accepts that this is what it is and this
is part of it and that's why he doesn't
he's not like frustrated and resentful
he so you know it's a part of life and
we're just hanging out and my dad
remembered Jamil is my best friend and
he goes oh [ __ ] how is Jamil man we
gotta have him come over and it was the
coolest thing because should like forget
so many things but remember somebody
yeah it was like had a profound effect
on like my life but also just like some
of the he really cared about and that
knew about like what a compliment I got
a text Emile about that but like what a
cool thing like your brain is only
locking into these deep-rooted memories
at this point there's no short-term
memory no new memories yeah it's just
the deep-rooted [ __ ] that's always been
there
yeah it's like [ __ ] what what you did
something man Jamil you [ __ ] you did
something you affected that guy's you
know life in a way where like he just
not gonna forget about you and so
there's nothing left it's pretty cool
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]